un organisme de défense des
droits des minorités sexuelles
a lancé une campagne de
sensibilisation pour lutter
contre les stéréotypes en milieu
rural. Des agriculteurs nous
expliquent pourquoi on a encore
besoin de faire campagne
en ce sens.
♪ ♪ ♪
- En ville, il y a un peu
plus de gêne, là. Ils iront pas
te crier : «Ostie de fife!»
en plein milieu de la rue.
Ici, ça va pouvoir, des fois,
arriver.
- Là, on arrive ici.
On est un couple binational.
On est un couple homoparental.
On est agricultrices.
On a deux filles qui ne
sont pas de la même couleur.
Ça faisait beaucoup.
- Quand je l'ai dit, que
j'étais gay, eux autres, dans
leur tête : Il peut pas être
producteur! S'il veut vivre sa
vie de gay, il faut qu'il s'en
aille à Montréal, qu'il devienne
coiffeur ou styliste, ou peu
importe. Ben, c'était ça!
- Je suis François Vanier. Je
suis à la direction générale du
Groupe régional d'intervention
sociale, le GRIS, en Mauricie
Centre-du-Québec.
Le domaine agricole est un
milieu qui est encore très
hétéronormatif : des hommes
musclés, donc qui reprennent
l'entreprise familiale,
par exemple, qui vont fonder
leur famille, ont leur femme,
ont des enfants. Le but de
la campagne, c'était de faire
tomber les préjugés.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Marie-Noëlle Brien. Je suis
copropriétaire de l'asinerie
Les ânes en culotte avec
ma conjointe. On est situées
à Sainte-Anne-de-la-Rochelle.
Ce qui va déranger, c'est qu'on
soit deux femmes sur une ferme.
Les messieurs, ils arrivent ici
puis ils se demandent : Il est
où l'homme? On a des ânesses
laitières. Donc nos ânesses,
elles produisent du lait avec
lequel on fait des cosmétiques.
On accueille des gens sur
la ferme, l'été, en tourisme.
C'est arrivé plusieurs fois
où la dame du couple va dire :
«Oui, mais le tracteur, qui
est-ce qui conduit le tracteur
si vous êtes deux femmes?»
Bien, c'est ma blonde
qui conduit le tracteur!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mon nom est Dave Labrie.
J'habite à Saint-Cyprien, dans
la région de Rivière-du-Loup.
J'ai 43 ans et je suis
producteur de lait.
♪ ♪ ♪
Même moi, des fois, je me dis :
Hein? Il est producteur de lait
puis il est gay! T'sais, je fais
comme : Ah ben, moi aussi.
Ben oui, c'est vrai. T'sais,
c'est tellement ancré dans
les gens, dans la société que
ça va juste aider à démystifier
tout ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est Alain-Charles Courcy.
Je réside présentement à
Saint-Charles-de-Bellechasse.
J'ai aussi un autre nom qui est
mon surnom que tout le monde
m'appelle, c'est Alix de Courcy,
qui est mon nom de scène
en tant que drag queen.
(en style opéra):
♪ Je vais à l'étable
pour tirer ma vache ♪
♪ Mais je suis pas capable
de tirer ma vache ♪
- Là, je suis fermier
maintenant; en fait,
agriculteur, dirais-je.
(en style opéra):
♪ Chocolat chaud! ♪
La vie avec les animaux, ça a
un rythme qui est complètement
différent de celui des humains.
Puis c'est ça qui est le fun.
Mais on l'a dit tout de suite
en partant : «On est un couple,
on est là. Vous nous prenez
comme on est.» On avait tous
les deux le même rêve! J'aurais
jamais fait ça tout seul.
- Je suis certaine qu'en
cinq ans, t'as senti des
préjugés envers vous.
- Oui! Souvent, c'étaient
des propriétaires de magasins,
qu'on rentrait là, puis là...
Le regard! C'était...
Je pense que si j'avais été,
je sais, moi, Anne-Marie Losique
qui serait rentrée, ça aurait
fait le même effet, là!
Puis je me suis même déjà fait
refuser l'entrée en me faisant
dire : «Des personnes comme toi,
on prend pas ça ici.»
Je m'en allais «tanker».
- OK! Donc, t'étais habillé?
- Oui, oui, j'étais habillé de
même! Le propriétaire aimait pas
ça; il est homophobe. Ça arrive.
- Est-ce qu'il y en a encore
qui souffrent d'homophobie dans
le milieu agricole et rural?
- Oui. Oh oui.
Un, c'est un cas d'homophobie,
mais de ses parents. Le jeune
garçon, c'était dans les plans
qu'il achète la ferme familiale.
Finalement, le gars rencontre un
autre garçon. Il est en amour,
le dit à sa famille, le dit
à ses parents. Ses parents le
prennent pas, mais vraiment pas.
Ils ont profité du fait qu'il
était absent, ils ont tout
vendu, ils ont tout liquidé
l'entreprise. Puis son père
de lui dire : «C'est pas vrai
qu'une tapette va avoir ce
que ma famille a construit.»
C'est pas si loin!
C'est pas... Quatre ans,
peut-être! Oui, oui.
- J'ai vécu toute ma jeunesse
en campagne. J'ai travaillé
dans les fermes, j'ai travaillé
aussi dans les écuries.
En ruralité, j'étais tout seul!
En ville, probablement qu'il y
en aurait eu d'autres comme moi;
là, il y aurait eu une
différence. Là, j'étais vraiment
unique, j'étais vraiment...
J'étais LA tapette du coin, là.
On va le dire de même.
Je vivais des problèmes énormes
d'injures, d'injustice.
Bref, je vivais le préjugé
des autres parents. Parce que
les enfants, ils connaissent pas
ce qui se passe! Mais c'est eux
qui le font. Puis des enfants,
c'est méchant.
- À l'époque, j'avais une
blonde; c'était pour cacher les
apparences. À un moment donné,
je me suis dit : «Eille,
là, là, ça ne marche plus.»
Là, c'est moi qui s'est remis
en question. J'ai dit : «Soit
que j'arrête ça là ... j'ai même
eu des idées noires, on se
le cachera pas, ou soit que
je finis ça là, la relation,
ou que je finis ma vie là.
C'est un ou l'autre.» Puis moi,
je suis quelqu'un qui a quand
même une bonne joie de vivre.
J'ai dit : «Je peux pas faire
ça.»
- Le taux de suicide chez les
agriculteurs est encore très
élevé. Ce sont des personnes
qui sont grandement isolées
aussi dans leur quotidien.
On se lève tôt, on se couche
tard, donc on est constamment,
24 heures sur 24, sur la ferme.
Mais qu'en plus, un agriculteur
se questionne sur son
orientation sexuelle ou même
son identité de genre, ça peut
être problématique, en bout
de ligne, pour la santé mentale
de la personne.
- Combien d'amis, moi, j'ai
qui sont partis de la campagne,
de Montmagny, qui sont partis
de Saint-Damien parce qu'ils
ne pouvaient plus rester!
Leur famille aimait pas ça
qu'ils étaient homosexuels!
Puis comment... Si t'as pas de
support de ta propre famille,
comment tu veux sortir de ça?
C'est vraiment la solitude qui
devient le plus grand problème
en région pour les gens
homosexuels. Où est-ce qu'on va
se retrouver? Qui peut parler...
Avec qui je pourrais parler de
ma réalité? Mon Dieu, j'ai dû
défaire deux de mes enclos, j'ai
été obligé de tasser mes brebis
puis demain soir, j'ai un show
de drag queen. À qui je pourrais
parler de ça?
- Même mes parents, quand ça
s'est su, eux autres aussi, ma
mère la première, elle a dit :
«Oh mon Dieu, on n'a plus
de relève. C'est fini.»
Je faisais des deuils,
moi, là; beaucoup de deuils.
Puis là, je voyais mon avenir
qui s'écroulait. Même mon père,
il en a jamais côtoyé, ça fait
que dans sa tête, lui, je m'en
allais à Montréal puis je suis
habillé en drag queen avec la
petite sacoche sur l'épaule, là.
Moi le premier, la parade gaie,
c'est des gars qui se promènent
en string et qui font ça.
T'sais! Puis c'est tellement
une minorité! Mais nous autres,
en région, tout ce qu'on voit
à la télé, c'est ça!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quand on va voir un couple
d'hommes, ce qu'on va
s'imaginer, bien, c'est des gars
sur un char allégorique avec des
plumes. Donc, je pense que les
gens, la population en général,
ne voit que ça. Puis ça dérange
un peu plus.
Nous, on vit beaucoup en
famille, donc ce qui est
accepté, c'est la famille.
Peut-être que la population en
général va voir ça plus naturel.
Souvent, à l'école, Florane
se faisait dire : «Florane,
elle est chanceuse, elle, elle
a deux mères!» Elle se faisait
pas dire : «Florane, elle a
pas de père!» Les gens posent
des questions, on leur répond.
Puis on a choisi d'être
complètement transparentes.
Je rencontre une madame à
l'épicerie, elle nous demande :
«Oh, le père, il doit donc avoir
une belle couleur de peau!» Là,
je lui dis : «Bien nous, on a
choisi un donneur qui était
Haïtien.» Puis là, je vois le
vide dans ses yeux, la pauvre
madame! Puis là, je suis obligée
d'aller... d'aller plus loin
puis de lui dire : «Ben oui,
c'est ma conjointe qui l'a
portée puis on a eu besoin
d'un donneur de sperme. Donc,
on est allées vers un donneur
qui était mulâtre.»
- Mais pourquoi acceptes-tu
de répondre à des questions
comme ça, aussi intimes?
- Parce que ça... Bien,
c'est juste notre façon
de faire avancer les choses.
Si moi, je bloque à raconter
l'histoire de la base de notre
famille, quel message j'envoie
aussi à mes enfants? À mes
enfants, à leurs amis, à l'école
ou à la madame au village!
- Dans le fond, toi, tu me dis
que ton personnage de drag
en campagne, milieu agricole,
ça pose pas problème?
- Non! Ça pose pas de problème,
moi, de ce côté-là.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est un show, les gens le
savent. Ça s'est bien passé
parce qu'on avait de l'ouverture
d'esprit; et parce qu'on
est allés chercher les gens.
On s'est pas arrêtés sur notre
homosexualité. On a voulu aller
plus loin. On est des êtres
humains, là; c'est ça qu'on a vu
d'abord, là. Puis les gens l'ont
pris comme ça eux autres aussi.
- Ce que tu m'expliques, c'est
que ton père était homophobe.
- Oui.
- Qu'est-ce qui s'est produit
quand tu lui as annoncé?
- Autant il était de ce côté-là,
là, autant ça a viré en
complètement de l'autre côté.
Des fois, on en jase pour le fun
puis là, il dit : «J'étais con,
hein?» Bien, je lui dis :
«Tu connaissais pas ça.» T'sais,
on a toujours peur de ce qu'on
connaît pas, peu importe c'est
quoi. Bien lui, c'était ça.
Puis comment on va me percevoir
dans le village, aussi. Je me
posais beaucoup la question.
J'avais peur de remettre
les pieds à l'épicerie, à la
quincaillerie, peu importe où.
Puis j'ai jamais vu
de différence. Puis là,
j'ai fait : «Ah! OK!»
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pourquoi toi, t'as accepté de
nous accorder une entrevue dans
le cadre de ce reportage-là?
- Pour donner de l'espoir.
Pour donner de l'espoir puis
dire aussi que la différence
se vit, aujourd'hui.
Que vous soyez en ville ou
que vous soyez en campagne,
il y a aura toujours, toujours,
toujours des préjugés. Il faut
juste aller au bout de soi.
C'est un rêve? Allez-y!
Votre rêve va vous porter.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je trouve qu'on est un modèle
équilibré, qu'on s'est intégrées
dans la... là, dans la vie
rurale. Ça adonne que c'est ici.
Sans se cacher, sans
en faire trop. Nos filles,
elles sont comme les autres.
C'est juste de montrer qu'on
est comme tout le monde!
- Je comprends qu'il y en a
qui veulent pas en parler
publiquement. Moi, ça me dérange
pas parce que je vis bien avec
ce que je suis. Je vis bien
avec mon conjoint. C'est ça,
c'est pour montrer aux gens
qu'on peut avoir une ferme
laitière, être gay, en couple,
heureux.
- Merci!
♪ ♪